I could befall another one like it was
an 85 like when all that and rising it
was going on and what was wild was that
the guy who looked the most like like a
bitch was hitting on the women you and I
had a jheri curl was coming my six
inside and all that if you wear baggy
now I'm blacking hard if you from LA you
must be in the club we get that groove
all shaking it up and Prince came that's
when Purple Rain came out and Prince was
the you know I'm saying
Prince had one like it was like a Zorro
tank outfit had the ruffles come down
Brett yeah big
his face it looks like it's something
that a figure skater would wear I'm
saying
and he used with his whole crew and he
had his other cat named Mickey free and
Mickey free was like the new cat and
Shalimar that when he joined a group I
heard man catch like yo shot ball got me
new girl in them if it's for like a
month okay with you free is not a girl
all right they came over where we was at
Prince I talked to my brother
hello Eddie Murphy a big fan of your
comedies would you like to come to my
house and listen to some music oh that's
cold
fruity get the car assembly your crew
I'll be outside
we went up we get they put the tracks on
tracks of slammin you don't mean
listening to the music and anything
groovin at the crib that get girls over
there yet nice environment it was it was
tight this bores me there's anyone up
for a game of basketball how about you
and your friends versus me and the
revolution
[Laughter]
so I was thinking must be joking me out
all the way to go he was dead serious
he had his uh help or whatever go and
get some like shorts and sneakers and
gave them to us and laughing I'm like
this is gonna be the funny ass so they
come out right and I look at them you
know they still got on the same
[Music]
wow that was like I know they anything
about playing ball in that but they work
say hey you know what
yo we gonna call this the shirts against
the blouse and when I said that this
look came on his face
and I'm looking back at him thinking to
myself no what are you angry about I
mean you know what you got that shirt
damn sure wasn't the men's
department I mean I kind of learned
something they didn't then that would
judge a book by its cover this cat could
ball me play ball he was crossing cat
who's getting rebounds like Charles ball
smashing it down to Jay trying to play
computer blue darling pinky day was kind
of setting these fruity pigs man you
don't think that you'd be trying to
check prints and then you got this cat
standing behind you and he's getting
close to you in his hands is out like
this you don't really want to be bent
over when a cat like that
print incredible we've got a towel man's
kind of hot out here me why don't you
purify yourself in the waters of Lake
Minnetonka good and your face Charlie
Murphy good good hustle yo now I'm not
on your team
I mean it wasn't even like he was close
it was a landslide victory game blouses
yeah you don't believe me you think I'm
making it up
you think I'm cause I'm telling you a
story about prank big challenge prints
to the game the ball one old world
challenge you all right and let make
sure your people is there to see the
game cuz you might get embarrassed trust
me
all right he beats him basketball and
then what happened after it was all over
he took us in the house of service
pancake
well I gotta admit them it's a good game
I wish I could say the same for you real
monkeys do you guys want some grapes I
mean you know there's some great
storytellers in the world we live in
today man bitches
[Applause]
you